- On this episode, I
talk time, time, time,
content, content, content,
and health, health, health.
(rhythmic hip hop instrumental music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching the
#AskGaryVee Show, episode 21.
Fun fact about the number 21,
is most of you really
cared about turning 21.
I didn't give a (beep).
- [Voiceover] Pedro asks,
"What's your best tip
for time management?"
- Pedro, actually, I don't know.
My tip for time management
is to have an assistant
who you make the czar of
your time and there's this.
Let's go find Matt DeMayo actually.
Let's get out of the cube a little bit.
Let's see if we can find DeMayo.
So for me, the time
management is humanly scaled.
What I basically do is
I find a human being
that allows me to do it
and so in this scenario,
that dude is my,
that's my answer for time management,
putting human being who
actually is the czar.
Matt, would you say
you're the czar of time?
- That might be a bit
much but I'm good with it.
- And so, he knocks on the window
and says your next meeting
and he texts me and he's
like, "Are you on this call?"
So, that's what I do.
I use human beings.
Obviously, using a human
being to manage your time
is not very practical
for most of the audience.
So, I'm going to try to
give some practicality,
which is I really don't know
because prior to using a human being,
I didn't really have a great system.
Obviously, we have technology now,
like phones that buzz
you and Google calendars.
I don't know how people do it.
I just think it becomes a religion.
I decided my time was worth a lot to me
and I created infrastructure around it.
For me, it was humans.
For you, it's got to be something
that reverse engineers
your actual behavior.
- [Voiceover] Danami asks,
"Why are you uploading
the episodes to Facebook
"instead of attaching a photo
"linking to your website of
the video or using YouTube?"
- The reason I'm posting this
video in Facebook natively
is because I fancy myself as an expert
or someone who at least
wants to be one day an expert
in really understanding things like,
you know, what the book was written about.
Can you get it back there, DRock?
- [DRock] Yup.
- Jab, jab, jab, right hook.
A lot of you read it.
You know that I care about being native,
being platform specific.
I am seeing data that shows me
that if I put the video
in natively and upload it
versus linking it to
YouTube or my website,
about 20 to 30,000 more
people see the video.
I care about them seeing the video.
I don't need to feel good about
where my traffic comes from.
I don't need the vanity of
having more YouTube views.
I don't need to see my
website getting more traffic
because I'm gonna sell ads on it.
I want people to hear the
answers to the questions.
I'm playing the long game.
I want to bring value.
The more people that see it,
the more value I'm providing,
If the feed natively is going to allow me
to reach more people, then
that's what I'm going to do.
- Hey Gary, how's it going?
It's Dom Garrett.
- [Gary] Dom.
- Just wanted to say
hello and ask you this.
As you know, I've talked
to you about it before.
I'm working on building an app
with one of my business partners
and while I'm in charge of adoption,
the app is probably six months away
from actually having a working prototype.
So, what would you
suggest I start doing now
to make sure that I'm building it up
so that when it does come to adoption time
and the app is released,
we have plenty of users that
are going to be using it.
Thanks a lot, Gary.
- Dom, first of all, good to see you.
Thanks for your hardcore
followingship over the last years.
I can't quantify it,
but I know we been jamming
hard for multiple years.
I'm going to give you
a really good answer,
and this is the answer that's
going to work for everybody,
no matter whether you have
an app or you sell clocks,
content, content, content.
Clock broke.
Content, content, content, content.
I think you need to put up.
So let's say you're
putting out a fitness app,
or a productivity app for time management,
you then need to create
timemanagement.com,
which is not available,
but dailytimemanagement.com or something,
and putting out content around the genre.
You need to create a
content portal on Medium
or your own blog or on RebelMouse,
which I believe in clearly.
Link it up.
And you need to,
you need to basically create content
to get like-minded people in that are,
you know, you come out with Fitness Daily
and yours is fitness
utility app and then boom,
you've got this audience
and when the app comes out,
you pound them with it and it comes out.
You need to gather people in a place
that are like-minded or
most likely to use the app,
and then when the time's
right, shout to them.
Jabbing and then right hooking.
- [Voiceover] Daniel asks,
"If you could teach everyone in the world
"one thing you've learned,
what would it be?"
- Daniel, the two things
I believe in the most
are empathy and gratitude,
but I don't think that's quite teachable.
Self-awareness, I don't
think that's. (chuckles)
This is the best.
I don't think that's teachable.
I think the thing that
I've been taught the most
through experience that was intuitive,
but I think is teachable,
is for everybody to pay attention,
that the world is really
about depth, not width, right?
And so do things that
are meaningful, not wide.
I'm just a big believer
in this depth width game.
I watch so, listen.
A lot of you guys know this.
I answered this question
two or three episodes ago.
I'm paying attention to you
as much as you're paying attention to me.
I may not be engaging and
replying on your posts,
or liking your comments,
or all those things
the way you are with me
because I'm doing it at such
a scale and I'm a busy mother,
and even that extra
second is tough for me,
but some of you've seen me,
especially on Instagram,
I'm definitely harding up and
replying and saying thanks.
But a lot of you
and this why I have so
much passion for it is
you guys are still in
the tactics of width.
You're looking for more likes and shares,
and like, a lot of right hooks
and you've read all my books
and you're like, "Yeah
Gary, you're right."
And then you're not doing it.
And here I am, busier than all of you.
Here I am, busier than all
of you doing this show,
providing depth, engaging at scale,
replying to your emails when they come in
trying to reply at scale on Twitter,
maybe not engaging with the
consumption of your content,
but definitely replying to when you care
and you want to be heard by me,
and I'm going deep, deep, deep,
while you shake your head
when I talk about deep,
but then you go out there and you go wide.
- [Voiceover] Edwards asks,
"If you could go back to your early 20s,
"would you prioritize health,
"or was neglecting it necessary
to get where you are today?"
- Edward, great question.
I wanted to address this.
One of the great things
of the show I keep saying
is that I'm going to answer questions
I haven't been able to answer,
and so, thanks for all of
you of getting me to 21.
But the other thing I get to
do is clear up some things,
so we're picking some questions.
I think I sent this one
to you Steve, right?
Yeah, we get to clarify on the show.
This is the clarity hour, my friends.
We get to clarify a little bit on the show
and what we are going to clarify is this.
I bet you a lot of
people are going to think
I'm going to go in one direction,
but I'm going in another.
The answer is I wish I
prioritized my health.
I could have slept one hour less.
I could have played one hour
less of Settlers of Catan
with my brother back in the day.
I could have worked, this is a crazy one.
I could have worked one less hour.
I could have done a whole lot of things,
but I should've found that one hour to do
what I've been doing for the last 65 days,
and prioritize my health.
So, if I could go back,
I'd be working out and eating
the way I'm doing it now,
all the way back since then.
Psst, real quick, I wasn't joking.
Leave more critiques.
Give me more feedback.
I love it.
I'm like a teddy bear. I want the hug.
My friends, thank you for allowing me
to be in your living room,
in your taxi or subway
ride with you on the phone,
or wherever you're consuming this content.
This show is really bringing back
a little bit of a blaze in my ass.
I don't know what that means
as it was coming out
of my mouth, but like,
I'm excited to be back in this game
that is a fun game for me.
For a while, you know,
people have tweeted out,
like Gary Vee doing what he does best.
I've seen that come around,
a lot of times I get pissed.
Best? What's best is I build businesses.
But there is some truth
that this seat feels
awfully comfortable to me
and you guys commenting,
all you people coming in
and saying, "I just caught
this show last week.
"I just found out about you six days ago,
"and I've watched all 21 episodes.
"I've been a lurker and following you."
I got to admit, you know what I call it.
It is the oxygen that
allows this show to continue
and I appreciate you tremendously.
And so, the question of the day
is very, very, very, very, very simple.
I want your thoughts on the new iPhone
'cause some of you are going
to have it over this weekend,
and on the Alibaba IPO.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
That was a good call out to the fans.
Some people are gonna have
some real moments there
with themselves.
(mouth-made whip sounds)
Hey, subscribe.
It matters to me. Subscribe.
And did you watch the last one?
And you better watch the next one.